[Musique]
l'après midi organisé voilà ça en dit
long
alors moi j'ai regardé les canadiens et
claude 4 et 6 les couloirs états unis
dans le cadre canada dans le 6 c'est
parti jean-marie esbly sont les deux
premiers quand même qui remettra à wanda
nesbit à breaking bad
l'homme qui était le plus rapide sur 100
m lancé voilà le relais qui laurence
mission et la transmission et c'est quoi
y
un petit mot
billy sur aisne
mais lee
et là c'est bon mais la commission
ouais soit en bio et laisse-moi bombe et
emmené
le réponse est partout
[Applaudissements]
mais
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
et pour lui sur un an
le centre
c'est un bon coureur avec la rage au
coeur et la remontée
l'extraordinaire regardez-le
c'est m
coups de masse
mas pour les amériques écoutez je
regarde à ces images de cette vidéo et
j'ai encore à plein d'émotions c'est
incroyable arrivé sur la plus haute
marche du podium voire la course au
ralenti voire le drapeau du voeu du
canada ici c'est vraiment incroyable
j'ai encore des rapports des frissons
aujourd'hui vous savez que c'est un site
un rêve que j'ai eu à à 17 ans et ce
rêve là je les dis je le dis ouvertement
à qui voulait l'entendre parce que moi
depuis que je suis je suis tout petit on
m'a toujours appris à persévérer
travaillé très fort et croire en ses
rêves à l'âge de 17 ans on me disait
beaucoup de gens me disaient bruni tu
rêves en couleur
beaucoup de gens me disaient que c'était
juge n'était pas réaliste et on me
disait que c'était impossible
j'avais jamais compris qu'est ce que ça
voulait dire impossible soit réaliste et
ainsi de suite
à l'âge de 17 ans aujourd'hui comme ma
conférencier j'ai la chance de voyager
un peu partout j'ai la chance de
rencontrer des gens et partager nos
objectifs nos rêves et ainsi de suite et
j'ai réalisé quelque chose je me suis un
moment je me suis dit pourquoi il ya des
gens qui ne persévère pas jusqu'à
l'atteinte de leurs objectifs
pourquoi certaines personnes dame n'aime
pas faire la compétition ne font pas de
compétition ce sera dans le sport ou
autre chose du passé
savez vous que c'est quoi la réponse la
peur
la peur incroyable peur de l'échec
un petit mois que je peux redire essayé
de remplacer ce mot par un mauvais
résultat vous traversé un moment
difficile
regarder le positif et dites-vous que la
prochaine fois ça va être ça va être
meilleur peur de perdre son temps que ça
soit on ne l'est pas ou quelqu'un qui
part en entreprise
le temps qui va falloir pour arriver
dans l'atteinte de nos objectifs
il ya une partie du cerveau qui va vous
dire peut-être que ça va pas réussir et
malheureusement beaucoup de gens qu'est
ce qu'ils font ils prennent un pas en
arrière corps des critiques des autres
la critique des autres c'est pas vos
affaires
laissez parler les gens concentrez-vous
sur vous mêmes peurs 2d seront et
croyable tout ce que vous allez faire
faites-le d'abord pour vous la peur on
me demande des fois
est ce que c'est normal oui c'est normal
nous sommes des êtres humains
pensez vous que j'avais pas part aux
olympiques et on regarde le stade
parfois 70 80 90 mille personnes on a
peur mais qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
dans ce temps là il faut changer notre
perspective est utilisée justement la
peur comme motivation supplémentaire
vers la ligne de départ zooey on a pas
mais il faut pas reculer
il faut l'utiliser à notre avantage et
c'est pour ça que je n'en prends
tellement de gens justement qu'ils
abandonnent leur rêve justement à cause
de ça
si j'avais laissé la porte mal et en
tire jamais j'aurais gagné cette
médaille d'or n'a jamais j'aurais gagné
quatre médailles aux championnats du
monde et d'autres prix c'est incroyable
le regard
d autres au cours de ma carrière j'étais
influencé par ça je me suis fait prendre
dans ce petit jeu encore aujourd'hui je
vois des gens qui se font prendre par ce
petit jeu les propre marque première
fois que je participe aux jeux
olympiques comme sprint à mon objectif
c'était d'arriver dans les cinq premiers
pour moi c'était normal je me disais
chute je suis capable mais le regard des
autres je voyais qu'il y avait un doute
vous pouvez lire dans les yeux déjà je
faisais des entrevues avant d'aller aux
jeux olympiques et je voyais que
beaucoup de gens avaient su doute là en
mes capacités
c'était comme un effet miroir et j'ai
cru à ça même en arrivant aux jeux
olympiques
j'ai acheté tous les journaux les
prédictions qu'ils sont les meilleurs
en arrivant à l'hôtel j'ai tout lu un
parent à un journal avait mon nom comme
finalistes
c'est ça que la société disait et là je
me suis dit c'est vrai je ne suis pas
assez bon
et cette peur là je le laissais
m'envahir justement je regardais la
foule
j'arrivais jusqu'en finale et je me
disais à l'intérieur de moi qu'est-ce
que je fais là je tremblais le regard
des autres laissez pas ne vous laissez
pas influencer par ça et la description
de la course c'était j'étais au couloir
numéro un au départ jusqu'à 10 mètres ou
est ce que les gens disaient que tout le
monde allait dépasser facilement
je voyais personne dans mon champ de
vision
alvin m toujours personne dans mon champ
de vision
à 30 mètres je me suis dit ça se peut
pas c'est impossible c'est pas moi c'est
ça que les gens m'ont dit jusqu'à 50 m
j'avais encore ce doute la jette encore
premier j'ai terminé en quatrième
position
mission accomplie mais j'étais tellement
fâchée contre moi parce que justement
j'avais pas cette confiance là j'ai
laissé 70 membres ailleurs à partir de
ce moment c'est là que j'ai commencé à
travailler avec un psychologue sportif
celle là qui a renforcé mon état
d'esprit de me dire je ne peux pas
contrôler qu'est ce que les gens pensent
de moi je peux pas contrôler la critique
envers mes performances
mon psychologue m'a aidé à me concentrer
sur moi sur tout ce que je pouvais
contrôler quelques mois plus tard en
l'on se retrouve au championnat demande
intérieure ou est ce que dans cette
époque j'étais l'un des meilleurs au
monde mais j'avais pas de titre encore
j'avais tout gagné mais compétition
presque une semaine avant la compétition
j'étais chez moi j'allais partir pour
les championnats du monde 7 heures du
matin ça sonne à la porte je rouvrir
je leur apporte mise en demeure
vous savez les défis vous avez toujours
vous allez toujours des obstacles dans
n'importe quel domaine que vous êtes
l'obstacle ce que je leur ai d'abord une
poursuite poursuite de 300 mille dollars
waouh qu'est ce qu'on fait est ce que
j'ai lu par extrêmement pas mais j'avais
une mission aussi dans quelques jours
qu'est ce qu'on fait visualisation
visualisation qu'est ce que le
psychologue me disais aussi il n'y a
rien qui me dérange
je vais aux championnats du monde je me
concentre sur moi je me concentre sur
mon couloir ma ligne de départ la ligne
du finish et je me vois les deux bras
dans les airs
c'est exactement ce qui est arrivé
j'avais beau championnat du monde
je me suis dit tout ce qui est à
l'extérieur on vit le moment présent
on a une mission mission accomplie
première fois champion du monde et c'est
comme ça que je pense continuer vers la
poursuite de main de ma carrière mais ça
va pas toujours bien on en parle souvent
de cycles cycle de la vie des fois ça va
bien ça va moins bien
et ainsi de suite l'appli vous les ports
que je vous disais la plus grande
déception que j'ai eu dans ma carrière
justement c'est à cause de ça c'est à
cause là de la part fort de décevoir
l'année olympique avant la mairie
je voulais aussi une médaille au 100 m
mon état d'esprit
comment il était je peux pas décevoir
mes parents je peux pas décevoir mes
amis je peux pas décevoir mes
commanditaires et je dois gagner cette
manière parce que je veux pas de se voir
mon pays
hu que c'est lourd sur le coup j'avais
pas compris c'est en arrivant au jeu en
demi finale des jeux olympiques et
j'étais deuxième au monde
et là il y avait deux demi finales mon
état d'esprit est là cette peur là
j'étais hanté et même du coup lors de la
préparation
j'aimais pas ce que je faisais deux demi
finales où est ce qu'on va prendre les
quatre premiers pour aller en finale
je termine ma course je regarde le
tableau indicateur
devenu serein canada 5e
j'ai pas réaliser encore pourquoi c'est
arrivé
en retournant à la maison ça veut dire
que fini les olympiques savez quand vous
arrivez au jour j on appelle le jour j
la journée où vous venez vous vous devez
performer au max ça fonctionne pas
qu'est ce qu'on fait il ya deux choses
essayer de savoir pourquoi vous êtes
dans cette situation
et deuxièmement qu'est ce que vous allez
faire le plus cher dès demain possible
sur ton à la maison et c'est là que je
regardais la la course puis je me disais
bruni pourquoi cette année mais pourquoi
tu es là et en plein milieu de la nuit
c'est l'objet réalisé weck
ou est-ce que mon état était bruni tu le
faisais pas pour toi tu faisais pour les
autres deuxième question qu'est ce qu'on
fait
le plus rapidement possible l'état
d'esprit on le met en à partir de
maintenant je le fais pour moi et je
vais avoir du plaisir
quelques heures plus tard à la maison
jeter dans la piscine et je m'amuse et
je me disais la vie est belle on a un
autre objectif on regarde vers la voir
les gens qui m'ont vu qu'ils m'ont
regardé quelques heures plus tard même
pas 24 heures qui vient d'avoir le la
plus grosse défaite de sa carrière on
parle des jeux olympiques qui arrive à
tous les quatre ans et quelques heures
le temps ça va bien ton état d'esprit
c'est ce qui est arrivé est ce qu on a
tous cette capacité oui absolument
il ya une fois quelqu'un m'a dit oui
mais des fois on pense ça sert à quoi de
d'essayer de faire quelque chose si on
sait qu'on va pas réussir
vous voyez on anticipe des résultats on
anticipe les chèques et ainsi de suite
à cette époque j'étais rendu à 29 ans la
critique
c'était quoi bruny surin
maintenant il est vieux il est trop
vieux devrait prendre sa retraite
il définit il a plus de jambes mais
qu'est ce qui se passe ici je savais
qu'il y avait encore quelque chose
trois ans plus tard on se retrouve en
j'aimerais ça vous montrer un autre ces
vidéos
bruny surin qui est là également le
canadien et qui sera lui au couloir
numéro 6 maurice greene au coude à coude
avec sur 1 c'est bien pour les chronos
c'est bien pour la bagarre le premier
départ était très propre avec un super
départ de morzine
sur un y à la population
je ne dis pas qu'ils partiront mais vous
risquez de passer qu'on balance
jésus
les jeunes
cette course j'avais terminé deuxième au
championnat du monde en 9 84 secondes
sur la distance de 100 mètres
ça m'a pris deux heures réalisé
qu'est ce que ça voulait dire cette
performance n'était pas juste deuxième
au monde
deux heures plus tard tous les médias se
font tester
j'attends mon tour et là j'ai eu un
déclic 19 84 j'étais rendu au classement
le deuxième performance
le deuxième humain le plus rapide de
tous les temps
à l'âge de 32 ans pourtant trois ans
avant sa critique des gens c'était quoi
il est trop vieux ils devraient prendre
sa retraite et ainsi de suite
qu'est ce que je peux vous vous
conseiller le regard des autres oubliez
ça valait porte quel domaine que vous
êtes
oui il va voir la peur mais justement
qu'est ce que vous devez faire
vous êtes soudaine de départ fait un pas
en avant
les autres vont suivre qu'est ce que je
peux vous conseiller trouver ou
retrouver votre passion entourez vous de
gens positifs et compétents essayez
toujours de sortir de votre zone de
confort et dans toute chose c'est quoi
cette préparation pratique visualisation
égale coin succès bonne chance à tous
google est
[Applaudissements]